miles garrett
the nfl sac leader right now with nine
and a half he had missed practice all
week due to an illness that was
wednesday and thursday the news came out
friday morning that he's on the covet 19
reserve list and then came the report
from the cleveland plain dealer that he
tested positive the circumstances
implied that because he'd been out of
practice with an illness but for
whatever reason he didn't test positive
until it would have been yesterday's
sample
analyzed off-site result late last night
early this morning
that's the biggest name yet to miss a
game due to covet 19. we haven't had a
franchise quarterback miss a game and
the next most important position in
football oh we did have cam never mind
uh
i still think miles garrett right now i
think it's i well let me let me try to
let me try to
let me try to clean the crap off my shoe
here the biggest player not named cam
newton is miles garrett and i i think as
consequential given the current
circumstances that the browns are in
where they're six and three
they're clinging to the bottom of the
ladder of the playoff hierarchy and
they've got
six games left wait they're six and
three they've got seven games left four
they should win
three they should lose if one of those
games they should win flips to a loss
that's nine and seven and that might
that may not get them in and and if it's
enough just to give carson wentz more
time and
have him get out of whatever funk he's
in
if if the if the eagles beat the browns
on sunday all of a sudden the browns are
on a track that very well could be no
post season
yeah this is huge mike i agree with you
whether it's the biggest
in the nfl this season or second to cam
newton however you want to phrase that
but he is as big a part of the browns as
cam newton is of the patriots there's no
question does lead the nfl and his force
four fumbles and i think he was right
there in that defensive player of the
year conversation now i still think
aaron donald is the favorite and tj
watts right there maybe he was third in
that conversation but he was right there
and let's face it the two teams he plays
and they play next the eagles they lead
the league and saks allowed with 35 he
was gonna have a big game probably this
week and then they play the jaguars next
week so this suddenly has become a huge
game for the browns without their
defensive leader adrian claiborne or
porter gustin is really going to have to
step up and do something in this game
for the browns
and they need them and they need them
bad because without miles garrett that
defense is not the same defense that
we've seen this season and it more may
be on baker mayfield too frankly to
produce more than he has this season
yeah you know they've got that great
running game with nick chubb and kareem
hunt but at some point baker mayfield
may have to win a game and it could turn
into not necessarily a shootout but it's
going to be easier for the eagles to
move the ball and score points than it
would have been if miles garrett were
playing and this is just part of that
that not quite avalanche but as peter
king pointed out earlier today on pft
live the numbers are way up of positives
and guys who are on covet 19 reserve and
the nfl keeps checking boxes one game
after another after another getting them
played i'm really concerned about what's
going to happen after thanksgiving after
everyone travels even though the cdc
says don't travel after everyone has
mini super spreader gatherings next
thursday while they eat and pass out and
watch football and share the virus and
take it back to their
home cities and a couple of weeks after
the fact it could be far worse for
everyone that it is now and it could be
far worse for the nfl
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports